the Joe Rogan experience how does it
feel to be a martial arts expert
somebody that can fight like do you feel
more confident going outside do you like
you know cuz I'm always looking around
like okay they make sure that guy
doesn't [ __ ] me up he can't even totally
kill me like you know whatever people
can always shoot you they can always
shoot you think it always stab you they
can always hit you over the head when
you're not looking there's always danger
and being a person especially when
you're around bad people right but if
I'm in a situation when there's some
guys that dick and you know I think like
I've seen people get beat up man that
couldn't defend themselves and it's
horrible to watch it's sad I mean we've
seen many videos online of people just
getting beat up by somebody yeah because
they don't know how to fight and you see
some person who really doesn't even know
how to fight and they're beating the
[ __ ] out of someone and hurt and I'm
really bad yeah that's not gonna happen
to me uh-huh
I like that I like that if some [ __ ]
tries to do that to me
I can I can hurt them I can detain them
I can I could submit them yeah but it
doesn't ever get to that point now have
you have you gotten in fights lately I'm
not a fighter I mean I know how to do it
but I'm a nice person so just knowing
that having a self-confidence but it
feels good feels n yeah but there's a
lot of sketchy people out there man
we've all seen videos and I watched a
video yesterday or some guy punching
some girl in the face for like no reason
and knocking her unconscious I'm like
what the [ __ ] people are [ __ ]
there's a bunch of people that are
abused and they come from horrible
backgrounds they're abused by their
parents or the family and they're
they're a mess and they they walk
amongst us free until they commit crimes
and they get locked in jail so if
somebody wants to fight me what I do I
just run get the [ __ ] out of there bro
you got to see it coming seeing it
coming is real that's a real important
part of it like seeing it coming right
away
seeing sketchy people and knowing you
gotta have that spidey sense I'm gonna
get the [ __ ] out of there but it's
exciting to be around danger that's it
for you it's exciting to be in weird
areas and be around weird people it's
like when things are a little bit a
little sketchy little seedy people enjoy
that there's like a it's like what do
you what would you rather have
would you rather have everything be
[ __ ] boring and vanilla and just
write everything is Hermosa Beach or you
know every now and then you want
something to be just a little bit
[ __ ] dirty makes you feel alive when
you do the shitty mics or like random
spots here and there there's a
grittiness to it yeah I think especially
stand-up so we really gravitate to that
yeah I think feels live we like a little
danger yeah we also like what you're
doing when you're doing stand-up is
you're kind of exposing these truths
that everybody kind of knows about but
doesn't talk about and it frees them in
a way like yes yes like there's like
there's thoughts that are there there
but you got a unearth them you know dust
them off and show them to people I'm
like yes yeah this is a danger to that
right there's a riskiness to what we do
be a Fisher something it's a weird job
man and everybody does it different
right you get the hedge Berg he does it
Mitch does it did it one way you do it a
different way Joey Diaz does it a
different way everybody's got a
different way of doing it but it's
ultimately you're trying to find those
points that get find that those
perspectives fine fine use those comedy
weapons to pop through on these people
and break into their mind and get those
sparks flying
[Applause]